The world is full of amazing rivers and lakes,...
...but one in particular really stands out.
Cano Cristales, commonly referred to as "the river that ran away to paradise,"...
...is a famous body of water in Colombia.
The river has a clear and calm current,...
...allowing visitors to see life underneath the water's surface.
Residing underwater is a range of rocks covered in green moss.
But for a period of time from September to November,...
...the water level dips, allowing the sun's natural heat...
...to warm that moss covering the rocks and other algae formations...
...beneath the surface.
The effect of the warmth results in a stunning transformation:...
...blooms grow beneath the water, ranging in all shades of colors.
A plant on the river floor turns vibrant red,...
...while the moss turns from slightly dull to bright green.
Algae plants that cover rocks turn shades of purple and magenta.
The water is so clear, it casts a sparkling blue appearance.
The river spans roughly 100 kilometers long.
The natural specimen is not easily accessible,...
...as visitors must venture through La Macarena and hike...
...or ride horses through unmarked trails.